for a long time people we're talking
about bullying and that was a big hot
topic and I think sometimes you can
forget that you could be your own bully
in some ways you don't have to be born
into a situation you don't have to come
from something or possess something or
look flawless even though I like looking
like this sometimes if you can believe
in something great I feel like you can
achieve something great she's an
American singer and songwriter she's one
of the best-selling musicians of all
time having sold over 100 million albums
worldwide her estimated net worth is a
hundred and twenty five million dollars
she's Katy Perry and here's my take on
her top ten rules of success rule number
five is my personal favorite I make sure
to stick around all the way to the end
for a special bonus clip also as katie
is talking if you said something that
really resonates with you please leave
in the comments below and put cool to
Remnant so other people can be inspired
as well enjoy
[Music]
for a long time people we're talking
about bullying and that was a big hot
topic and I think sometimes you can
forget that you could be your own bully
in some way it's like you were the
person that is standing in the way of
your success whether it's professionally
or personally and honestly that was the
case for me I was having a great
professional streak but personally I was
really immature and so I had to balance
them out finally I had enough and I said
hey you need to speak up for yourself if
you're not happy with something you
change it you know change it make
yourself better every single day so I
went to a lot of therapy and I I guess I
put it in the way of like you're gonna
hear me roar finally you're I'm gonna be
able to speak up for myself this next
record that I'll start in a couple of
months will be just a a I think it'll be
actually more honest because I think
when you get older you care less you
know what people think about you and I
have had to really work on that I think
that's one of the biggest things you
have to work on when you are put into
the spotlight is not caring about what
people say about you because you just
become like this open forum to anybody
anything anyone and if you start reading
your own press it will ruin you I feel
like I'm got the opportunity to make
more of a career rather than just like
you know a flash in the pan she's hot
she's not type of thing but that's only
because I have worked so hard and
focused you know and everything I do I
know it's for the fans and they're the
reason why I exist tell me about why you
decided to do this documentary oh my
goodness well I always like to be honest
with everything I do especially my songs
I like to plant those seeds of honesty
and truth because we live in a world
that doesn't have much of that left um
and with this documentary I wanted to
show people kind of like what was
underneath the hood yeah you can attest
to that I've been under the hood many
times
I really wanted to show people how how
much hard work it takes the ins and outs
and how really you don't have to be born
into a situation you don't have to come
from something or possess something or
look flawless even though I like looking
like this sometimes yeah um you can just
be you and have a dream and plant the
seed and water the root I found a lot of
self love this year and I kind of
rebuilt my confidence that had had a
little bit of a shatter to it and I went
in words rather than pointing the finger
on everyone else and blaming everyone
for my problems or the you know issues
that I had I went in words and tried to
kind of do some patchwork to kind of
heal up little spots that I need to heal
up or say to myself what can I do to
make myself a better human
representation why did you do I did a
lot of different things I did a cleanse
for three months that I didn't have any
alcohol and I did a whole vitamin
regimen and I went to therapy I did more
meditation I've been meditating for a
couple years now but I upped it and I
just with the positive rail rather than
like going to the club and getting drunk
every night
I mean I've probably done that a couple
of times but um I I really served myself
well and it influenced all of my
songwriting and I wrote most of the
songs during this time in the very
beginning of me getting into the
industry I would you know be out and
about and I would hear girls or
actresses or musicians or whatever you
know they would say oh no I don't want
to be in a relationship because I don't
want to have to choose between being in
a relationship and having a career and I
thought to myself
oh and I get to know that when I find
that person that's going to be my you
know life partner I won't ever have to
choose because they'll be accepting of
me completely for who I am not district
not not me being able to just like do
whatever I want
necessarily but they won't be threatened
or have weird motives or what they will
be accepting of me the things I love the
ambition what I aspire to be what I want
to create they'll be accepting and
supportive and then I started to realize
oh my god that's not true that's not
like that fairy tale that I had is not
true for me right now
yeah just a Miss yeah
[Music]
I'll tell you the truth is that I mean
I'm a romantic and I don't I kind of
believe in this fairy tale I mean and in
some ways I think that's always been to
my advantage because like if you can
believe in something great I feel like
you can achieve something great I have
that same belief system with everything
from went from career to my life my
personal line everything and I will do
everything it takes to not fail and I
did everything it took but it still
failed the bad that comes along with the
good is a journey I learned so much from
that journey why did you decide to come
out with roar like there was that big
countdown and then roar came out and it
was huge for you like I mean you broke
your own records there why was it roar
the first single um you know it was up
to up for debate a couple of singles it
was going to be roar or another one and
we decided to go with roar because of
the reaction I was getting from my
friends I kind of like use my friends as
guinea pigs as a test guinea pigs and I
have a very eclectic group of friends
ranging from you know DJ's to artists to
just moms um and they all really agreed
that roar was the best one and you know
it has that bouncy feel the eighth-note
feel but it also has this message of
finding your inner strength again and
letting that kind of come out as a roar
and people related to it yeah well they
really did and there's something yeah
there's something like there's an
intuitive thing that happens inside of
me and I've always trust my intuition
when it comes to writing songs and
picking which song should come out as
singles I've been onto a for a year and
before that I did promo for my record
and
record almost came out two years ago so
I've been doing a lot of work for that
for the past couple years and I think
what would be most important for me is
to kind of at this moment gather gather
my thoughts and and live a little bit of
life on my own and not around a
traveling circus of a hundred people and
have quiet moments and ride my bike and
kind of find my roots again that's what
I always do in between records is I I go
to a quiet place and restore my soul
I usually go back to my hometown of
Santa Barbara and figure out what all
this means and get away from the
distraction and feed my spirituality and
feed my music listening to a lot of
music and just getting my feet planted
back on the ground again
it's really important for me to live
life absorb life and have my own
experiences so that I can go back to the
drawing board and have something
authentic to say question the Katy Perry
via YouTube moderator how was life
before you became a celebrity before
your big break he's got the creepy voice
and that's okay okay I don't judge I
could be creepy too I mean if you saw me
in a purple widow walking down the
street you'd be like freak um well it
was all about the hustle and the bustle
and sometimes it was like you know me
trying to keep up with the Joneses as
they say like you know I wanted to be
seen like I was worth it and so I was
like trying to always be ready for
opportunity to present itself and it was
exciting you know it was a little bit
like not as fast-paced as it is now
things are just like so fast-paced like
lightning speed and you know I know what
I'm doing today and I know what I'm
doing probably in six months you know to
the date so it wasn't a scheduled um but
I mean I think I had a little bit more
time on my hands but I think that maybe
I might have gotten into a little bit
more trouble back then because you know
what is it Idol I'll yeah it might Oh
hands the devil's workshop is what my
parents said so now I really have a lot
to take care of but um it was you know
just about like working on my craft and
making sure that it was perfect so that
you know that when finally I would get
that opportunity I'd be ready for it
do you still believe in love of course
I'm going to let love lead the way
always and I was born with this blind
ambition it's kind of gotten me here to
this point and I think that I'll stick
to it
I just wanna wish you a
Oh
[Applause]
you
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because unlimited
traffic asked me to so if there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next please leave it down the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I also love to know what did you take
from Katie that had the biggest impact
on you what lesson you're going to apply
to your business or your life
please leave in the comments I'm going
to join in the discussion I also want to
give a quick shout out to my sister
Stephanie Carmichael thank you so much
for picking up a cup of my book and also
going to the bookstore and rearranging
it so that my book comes up first I
really appreciate that thanks for the
love so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
Transcendental Meditation to me is a
it's like a great workout for your mind
without working out but you get all the
effects of working out you know I come
from a very spiritual world from a very
religious upbringing and it's not
religious it's not spiritual although I
think if you're taking care of your body
in your mind that is a spiritual thing
but it doesn't have that kind of
religious background to me it's mostly
medical and it's like a little pill but
not a pill it's a practice so it's a
little practice that you do and it just
it to me it's a the most rest it's like
the most power nap you could ever get
and that experience of that quiet that
that is they call it state of restful
alertness according to science where
your mind is completely settled or
you're wide awake and it's sort of
before thoughts somehow someone said to
me well how do you know in your twenty
minutes are up I said well you can look
at your watch sure it's not like you're
going someplace but that peaceful state
that you access just happens quite
effortlessly and that's a wonderful
description yeah now why the part of one
more question how do you do how do you
think it's impacted your remarkable
career my life is so crazy
it really is it's extreme I live in this
1% tiled like extreme you know I'm sig
zagging all over the world I want to
play more than I am on ground and this
tool helps me find moments of peace
because I don't have a whole lot of time
that extend my day so I can live like my
fullest capacity like it gives me two
days in one day it just gives me this
power you know and I do it before I
write a song sometimes definitely before
I get on stage and it's just such an
incredible useful simple tool that has
made such an impact on me and that's why
I'm
here with you today um you're very calm
on tour at least with me because you
invited our whole team to come and teach
your 40 another 40 of your team to
meditate and I ran into you just outside
you're coming out of a room and we're
just sort of chatting and you look to
use it Bob you're 16,000 people waiting
for me right like right around the
corner if you just like did that you
were polite with me he just walked out
on the stage but there was such a an
evenness and a multitasker yeah you have
a great deal of kindness inside of you
thank you you're you know person thank
you I think that like it would be a
shame to have such a great cure all to
yourself like the cure for the common
cold and not to share it with people
that are suffering so it's the cure for
like the common stress which stress is a
killer these days and I have a lot of it
in my life and I have a great tool that
helps kind of subside it and I want to
share that because I don't want people
to suffer I like to lift people up